advances in medicine what are the limits
in the interview Nobel laureate very
marshal huzzah Masha you are physics a
scientist and you were granted a Nobel
Prize how did the Nobel Prize affect
your scientific research what impact did
it have it freed me up to do the
research that I felt like doing rather
than following the agenda of one of the
funding agencies so that did help me and
I was able to fill in some of the
weaknesses weaknesses in my own skills
by hiring excellent scientists from all
over the world to come to my lab so I've
enjoyed having the Nobel Prize and
having a top quality people working for
me did it change your personal life as
well I had to put more discipline into
my life in some some way so instead of
scheduling events I have to schedule my
time off because it's so difficult to
find the the rest time or the recreation
time so probably one day per week is
allocated for non-academic non-noble
activities with my family that's
something at least you know okay what
kind of framework does research in the
sciences need an order to bear fruit
from your point of view what kind of
conditions doing it I think we have to
have the long-term view and so many
countries do have a long-term view
although maps perhaps not funding it
adequately I suppose politicians they
come and go and so they're very
interested in things that just happened
in one or two like they're one basically
czar three years six years but what's
happened in modern times is that there's
so much regulatory oversight so much
safety precautions and registration that
goes on with new products that from the
from a discovery to the implicate
implementation of a
a new idea is far longer than it used to
be and it's the burden is on the
investigators to actually carry out all
these excess extra tasks that surround
the scientific process and so the future
I think is that the government's and
funding agencies need to provide
infrastructure to take those burdens
away from the investigators and the
people who are doing the problem solving
so they can focus again on the science
and the lead time link of assurant
mm-hmm now you prove that one bacteria
is responsible for most stomach ulcers
you proved that by experimenting on
yourself on your own body why was it
necessary so it's a good example of fast
tracking the research if you like we did
have this it is a tradition in medicine
that often new discoveries are tested
out by the inventor and the moral see
this is its sing off the path to be
honest okay it's still going on it's so
going on but the moral part of it is
that if I'm going to give a new product
or a bacteria to a volunteer obviously I
should be prepared to give it to myself
in the first instance and then I can say
yes well I know what happened I know
it's going to be dangerous or not and in
those days we had no animal models and
it's one of the very difficult things
with the new bacteria or any kind of new
thing in medicine is finding the correct
animal model so that you can test the
the new thing out in an animal let's see
what happens so we did not have an
animal model so in that respect it was a
little bit dangerous I guess diving into
the unknown but you took the bacteria
and you got say yeah so I drank the
bacteria and I was the fingers crossed
see what happens after a few days I felt
a little bit unwell and that became
worse and worse until I started having
vomiting attacks for three days and then
the vomiting subsided it was quite
interesting actually my mother told me
that I had a very bad breath halitosis
so I thought well that's interesting but
I didn't think about it very much until
later on I realized that when you first
catch the helicobacter it can remove the
acid from your stomach mm-hmm the
initial phase you want you will not have
an ulcer usually you may have no
symptoms Oh like you may have very vague
think's wrong with you like you feel
like the food is not digesting properly
or you may have a bad breath and I think
it's maybe that's one thing that I've
done for mankind is not quite so many
people have halitosis nowadays because
the helical vectors declining but now
people who have ulcers can be helped
through your research or because of the
results of your research that's a
wonderful thing to be able to cure and
you only so in the past if your doctor
diagnosed that you had an ulcer it was
like it wasn't it was not a death
sentence but it means you're the rest of
your life you are going to be burdened
by this continual chronic illness which
could be cool quite dangerous and kill
you whereas now if your doctor finds an
ulcer e says is but it's caused by
bacteria Helicobacter we can cure you in
maybe one week with special antibiotics
don't worry about it so it must be a
good feeling for you that's right every
patient would love to have a diagnosis
which can be immediately cured any go
back to normal so you don't want a
diagnosis that says all you're under too
much stress because you can't help that
that's part of your life but still would
you say there's a limit of our medical
research can go or should go well I'm
not sure what you mean by that work
whether you're saying that certain
things should not be done because
they're ethically find objectionable
like human cloning for example for
example well i would say at the moment
we don't know enough about those things
to use them on him as but of course we
can clone animals now and i would say
extrapolating out eventually we would
clone human so i don't really see that
there is a moral objection to my mind I
don't think that once the science is
understood if we sort of benefit from
finding him as I wouldn't have any
objection to that but what you really
want this kind of society who can which
can do
well the first thing is going to happen
obviously is genetic screening to
protect people from having children with
a known genetic abnormality so we could
say that in the next 20 years in most
countries there would be the option of
getting your genome performed and having
an analysis of your genome by your
family doctor a confidential consultant
and then if you young married couples
would be able to look at they're both
genomes in software and see if there are
any mutations which they would like to
avoid so certainly there are familial
diseases the first one of course would
probably be cystic fibrosis and so at
the moment that is a very serious
disease which your children might have
which might have never been in your
family so I would say cystic fibrosis is
an obvious one which you would like to
test for but isn't there also the risk
of Miss using science you know how well
come on TECA this you know well there is
at the moment I would say that it's not
a problem it's not something we need to
worry the restrictions we have on
science and limitations and ethics
committees things like that I don't
think that they are burdening science
particularly much because of course most
of these things that we're developing we
it's going to be so long since we before
we know all about it yeah before we
could say that it was safe to do an
experiment obviously I think already now
there are things happening the science
is actually advancing faster than the
ethical supervision and not sort of them
probably yes well that's a problem for
the scientists and I think the
legislation always follows the advances
and so we need to watch that obviously
there are things that have happened in
the past which were very very bad for
instance in the in the 70s I recall
there was a one-year moratorium on
genetic engineering and bacteria so in
that one year that delayed the
development of human insulin by one year
so how many poor diabetics might have
died in that 12 months or have what was
the cost in the human costs in
x why not having human insulin available
so that was one example I know at the
moment there is a an unreasonable amount
of concern about genetically modified
foods particularly here in Germany on
you you know but I think that that's a
the problem is that the communication of
science has failed in somewhere and the
communication of non science is very
successful and one of the reasons is
because things that are just simple
natural products even if they are
useless are not regulated so they don't
carry the regulatory burden to be
actually sold in the marketplace where's
this scientific and the drug products
are regulated so much there's very
difficult to actually move forward and
expose people to the science there so I
think certainly there needs to be more
emphasis on scientific communication the
morals of science is a kind of moral
debate also between science how their
research could be used or misused it
well I I know you know there are
examples of that in Germany and I was I
recall it the the the scientist who
invented the is it the harbor process
the the manufacturing urea from nitrogen
for instance he was also the person that
invented poison gas and bombs and things
like that also Alfred Nobel made most of
his money out of dynamite and of course
munitions exactly so I suppose there
needs to be some thought about that and
in my area of say genetic engineering
molecular biology there is I think the
over side of it at the moment is quite
stringent and quite successful one of
the things that's allowed us to do that
of course is the internet the
information technology that's available
so if i have anything every obviously
every chemical every bottle of reagents
in my laboratory has got to read a line
in in the computer and someone can
access my computer from the university
or the federal government and say dr.
Marshall show me what genes you are
manipulating in your laboratory well is
it
ument there and we can see what they are
and of course I can't even import the
reagents into the country i buy them
with special permits so I don't have a
problem with that because i know it's
working so some bureaucracy is it good
yes because of course you know 20 or 30
years ago every government was working
on World War germ warfare which these
days with modern technology if you
worked on what a germ warfare you could
certainly make something terrible just
in your own laboratory everybody could
do it so obviously we want to regulate
that and so you can you could not easily
start from nothing and develop a germ
warfare warfare or molecular bolit
biology these days because you would
have all kinds of signals coming out of
your operation so I think these are
going to happen in science fiction
movies good but like my thats but
hopefully not heed not in real life at
the moment ok thank you very much for
that interview thank you